steve
you may have a good collection behind
you
but i'll tell you what you don't have
oh i know what i don't have you don't
have lori strode with
you may have a lot of your toys but you
don't have lori strode with hot dog
fingers
that you
you've challenged him now right first of
all there's no challenge i am i am more
than happy to let you have the mantle of
of queen of toys i i i see one toy by
the way made by the daniels for me on
first day of shooting
everything everywhere all at once
i absolutely love it and i do hope this
is the beginning of cool toys from this
film i i hope so too i have to start
with and i'm sure you're hearing this
from everyone how much i loved this
movie it is phenomenal i know every i
mean i have nothing but positive things
to say about this film um and i just
want to know for both of you uh what was
it actually like reading a script like
this for the first time because it is so
unlike anything that's out there and so
unique and original and it's why i love
movies
michelle it's all about you talk go baby
well you've just put it like in a
nutshell steve you know when i first
read it it's exactly that like i've
never read a script
dedicated to a very ordinary
aging asian
mother housewife that you know and i've
said before it's like this is a woman
that you pass by on the streets when you
go to the supermarket and you never
notice her
she's just taken for granted nobody
really cares about her and suddenly
these daniels have given her such a loud
voice such a voice that
only in a sci-fi movie
that it can explode in these crazy
multi-verses where she can she's
actually a superhero
so when i read that script it was like
my god i've been waiting how many years
for someone to be so bold and courageous
and write something like that put it on
paper and have them a24 say yeah
if michelle yo does it yeah i think we
can do this movie yes
and then we have jamie lee curtis
who read it once and couldn't understand
a word except
except
i've been to the irs i know deirdre
balbirdres
as long as i understood her
that's all i needed to understand the
rest of it i just kind of went with it
as the day went by so i it's funny i
didn't read it all that much i really
only read it because i
felt like i had to i would have done the
movie without reading it simply because
michelle was going to do it so in the
same way that 8 24 green lit it
i i said yes because michelle was doing
it because
i'm going to get that chance to and it's
just truth i mean i'm not trying to you
know i mean at this point we're blowing
smoke up each other's butt so much that
you know we're gonna
we're gonna lose good barriers but the
truth of the matter is that is the truth
of the matter that i said yes because
michelle yo was doing this movie
no also
also i did hear that they promised you
an action figure with a hot dog
no this is my laurie strode action
figure they didn't this isn't a deer
drip over you can actually see it's a
weirdly good likeness of me you can't
really see it but
they
single-handedly made me uh uh lori
strode with five dog hands
what one of the things that i can't
believe about this film is that it was
shot in like 30-something days i believe
37 38 days yeah right which when you
watch the movie it doesn't add up like i
don't understand because i know how
movies are made and this is impossible
so for both of you how how was this made
in such a short period of time
working every day
um one shot at a time these people know
what they're doing
knew exactly what they were doing you
know they they knew the script inside
and out backwards and forwards up and
down and all the way around it was like
they were the everything bagel they had
everything inside that those two heads
you know they were they're like the evil
geniuses
but the i think the most important they
were so well prepared that they were
able to find the time to try
adjustments along the way and i but i
remember very clear distinctly sometimes
you go like
that
what are we gonna do he's like try it
this way so they knew very specifically
and they were also because i think they
come from that world of editing and
their technical geniuses with the camera
and locking our dp
so they caught everything that they
needed
they always managed to shoot all the
things that they needed and more in a
very short period of time because they
knew exactly what they
they had to have and what they needed
because they were editing as they went
along and paul our editor
yeah well what the hell he did but he
did a brilliant job but they were also
incredibly well prepared
can't do a multi-verse
no sci-fi martial arts oh not dramatic
without being
involved absolutely well prepared so
we would be one day jumping from this
universe to the next i'm in the closet
and then i'm out of the closet and i'm
in a different outfit and i'm like which
universe did you come in oh anyway
you're gonna die just lie there like
did you what you know
but they would they knew exactly what it
was that note i need to already stop i
really mean it sincerely i love this
movie so much i wish you both nothing
but the best oh thank you so much yeah
we're so happy to be here together yes
you this is this is great
so here i'll wave goodbye with my hot
dog hand bye bye